Speaker 1: Tax the rich is a popular slogan
among the left. Taxing the wealthiest is actually
quite well supported by Americans across
political parties, although certainly less
so by Republicans, although tax the rich is
relatively popular overall. But taxing the
rich is actually difficult if what we're talking
about is collecting taxes from the rich. And what
I mean by that is many of the methods proposed
to tax the rich either wouldn't really tax the
rich because the rich would find ways around
them, or they would be completely impractical.
So I'll explain. You raise income taxes. You
say we're going to raise that top tax rate of
on income from 36 to 39 to 42 to 50 to 60. OK.
Most of the very rich aren't earning their money
through income through wages, so they're not
actually going to be impacted by an increase to
the top income tax rate. They make a lot of money
through capital gains. OK, well, so then you say,
Well, let's raise capital gains. The rich making
money from dividends and making money from money
will have to pay if we increase the capital gains
tax rate or tax capital gains as we do income. OK.
Well, there's a way around that as well. The rich
can choose not to realize the capital gains. To
avoid those taxes. They can wait around for the
next president or the one after that to lower
the tax rate on capital gains. Or they can create
charitable foundations, which they control or use
other mechanisms. OK, well, you've got the estate
tax for people who die with more than a million
dollars or 22 million for couples. There we've
got them, right? Well, not really, because you can
reduce tax liability there as well with all sorts
of other mechanisms, including stepped up basis
Delaware dynasty trusts. I could go on and on as
a business owner, you can reduce taxable income by
contributing to a defined benefit plan and then
you earn income from the plan, paying taxes on
income later when your income may be lower, but
reducing income taxes in the immediate. OK, well,
hold on. So then let's do a wealth tax. Let's
tax people's assets, even unrealized gains on
those assets. I've already explained why I think
it's untenable, and some of you disagree with me
many times. For the very wealthy net worth is tied
up, either in their business and physical assets,
in accounts receivable. In stocks with unrealized
gains, you may not actually have the liquid assets
to cover a wealth tax. And then imagine that
you pay such a tax on stocks you haven't sold.
And then next year, the market crashes and you
lose value in those stocks. Are you entitled to a
refund on the net worth tax that you paid? As I've
said before, I believe it's completely unfeasible.
I think there's essentially no chance that what
Elizabeth Warren is proposing on a wealth tax
passes. And part of what I'm getting to here
is something called the dynamic tax model.
When you do a tax model and you score it, how
much will we collect? You really should do it
dynamically, meaning you account for how people's
behavior will change based on the tax plan. So
I'll give you an example. If right now we say,
listen, if you look at people's income right now,
if we were to raise the top marginal tax rate
from 37 percent to 45 percent, we'd collect
$200 billion. I'm just making these numbers up.
That only holds if we assume nobody changes their
behavior. But the truth is, if you announced
the tax is changing from 37 to 45 percent, that
top tax rate many people subject to the top tax
rate would reduce their income. Take it in stock
deferred compensation, move personal expenses to
business expenses, etc. So you need to score these
proposals dynamically to account for changes in
behavior. And when you do that, you realize that
the actual government revenue change from
a lot of these proposals is much smaller
than what we might have immediately imagined.
OK, great. So these are all the problems.
How do we actually collect taxes from the rich?
I actually don't know, because just about every
individual change that I've read about can at
least be partially defeated, somewhat mitigated.
And even if not, people always can abandon
the U.S. or whatever country has the tax and
go elsewhere. Now, it's not that easy to do in
the United States. You may have to renounce your
citizenship in the United States to avoid taxation
in the United States if you're a citizen. But
let's talk about what might actually
work. My conclusion after studying this
for a very long time is if you really
want to collect taxes from the rich,
you and other countries need to basically take
all of the above approach to make it really
difficult to avoid taxation. It's not even going
to be impossible, but you've got to start calling
people's bluff about leaving the country, for
example. I think that's what it would take. So
you've got to raise the top marginal tax rate on
income. You've got to tax capital gains as income.
You've got to eliminate the stepped up basis for
the estate tax. I've talked about it before. We
don't I'm not going to explain it in this segment,
but there I have segments on it. You've got to put
in a more aggressive alternative minimum tax for
higher earners. You've got to do it all together
and say, Listen, if you really want to avoid
this stuff, you'll have to leave. And maybe
other countries will do the same thing, by the
way. So then where where are you leaving to?
And most people aren't actually going to abandon
their country in this case of the United States,
and you're going to be able to pick up some taxes
from all of these different things. I don't think
there's really any other way to reliably collect
taxes from the rich. I understand passing policy
that targets the rich, but actually collecting
is the difficult part. If you have a better idea,
let me know, but I think that that's what
it would take. Reminder, we are six days
from the David Pakman show Live Town Hall. This
will be streaming live. Tuesday, October 19th.
6:00 PM Eastern will open up the phone lines for a
while. We will be streaming live only on The David
Pakman Show second channel called Packman Live.
You can find it at youtube.com slash Pacman Live.